[Music]
james our producer handed me a sheet a
minute ago this is so interesting
uh farhad
manjo i guess that's how it's pronounced
i may have messed up your name there sir
i apologize
has a whole section in the new york
times on abolishing millionaires
a billion dollars is wildly more than
anyone needs
even accounting for life's most
excessive lavishes
it's far more than anyone might
reasonably claim to deserve
however much he believes he has
contributed to society billionaires
should not exist
when american capitalism sends us its
billionaires it's sending not sending us
its best it's sending us people who have
lots of problems and they're bringing
problems with them they're bringing
inequality
this from a guy who is a reporter
with student loan debt from his
journalism degree but
uh this is you know this ultimate tall
poppy syndrome
poppy sticks up its head above the
others it must be cut down
and so we're supposed to be
jealous and
envious to evil ideas to carry evil
character traits of anyone who is one
with money evil money is evil
money is bad
if you get money you are evil and you
are bad and you should have it taken
away from you and given to someone else
so that they are evil and bad i guess i
never thought about that part yeah but
um if we give it out is it not a problem
to the poor people that get it i mean if
it's bad maybe we should just centralize
it with a few people and destroy them
instead of giving it to other people
that's kind of illogical the critical
thinking breaks down on this doesn't it
mr buffett is actually the most
dangerous kind of billionaire we have
this guy says
the worst billionaires are good
billionaires the sort who make it seem
like the problem is the distortion of
the system when in fact the problem is
the system
there should be no way that anyone has a
million or billion dollars in america
these are the voices that are out there
um now i'm old
when i was young we call those
communists
what's that
who didn't want people who act this way
that say these kinds of things this is
straight up marxism
i mean it's uh but this idea and of
course aoc's policy advisor dan ripple
comes out and contends that every
billionaire we have is because there's a
policy failure the acquisition of that
much wealth has bad consequences and a
moral society needs guard rails against
it
see that's straight up marxism
so let's take so i'm just thinking of
the first guy that popped into my head
um
everybody's favorite target elon musk
comes up with
a cool computer program and sells it for
a lot of money helps a lot of people do
a lot of things then he develops
a car and a battery
here's the thing what's the inherent
evil there i'm perplexed by the argument
well it is not and it's not logical it's
not critical thinking skills marxism
never is so what ends up happening is
that that the whole thing is about
vilifying
wealth and the wealthy okay so that we
can do a power grab
and move the money around and get credit
for it
it's a power grab thing
um and it that's generally what is at
the core of marxism or these kinds of
things all along so
here's what actually happens though in
the real world okay not in these
people's little fairy tale minds that
they have
in the real world the most generous
people on the planet are the wealthy
no really this is actual data
not theory not political rhetoric that's
trying to beat a drum but the actual
data says
that wealthy people feed more starving
children than not wealthy people do
88 gave to a charity in 2020. 88 of
affluent households donated in 2020
in a year with a global pandemic and
other crisis where people were scared to
death
there was a record of philanthropy nine
out of ten
nine out of ten households the study of
a survey of 1626 households with a net
worth of one million dollars or more
millionaires
there they are again
excluding the value of their primary
residence which means they're worth more
than a million considerably
annual household income of 200 thousand
dollars
these were the people studied of them
they gave 88 percent of them donated to
charity yeah
and and i got to tell you that
everything we get our hands on about it
says that they not only donate to
charity they consistently donate to
charity and it is substantial yeah
um
but yet they are
by marxist journalism student at the new
york times are evil
evil rich people and and everyone knows
that a camel can't go get through the
eye of the needle so
we know that rich people aren't going to
heaven right according to atheists who
misquote scripture and don't understand
it on twitter
right i don't know i know some believers
that quote that too but i know yeah but
they're they're ignorant of the they
need to work on their bible study skills
and so because it's a problem because
here's the thing that is actually when
you take that stance as a christian
that's actually gnosticism
which is a first century form of heresy
let me walk you through this okay
if
rich people can't get to heaven if
that's your conclusion of that scripture
because you didn't read it in context
and you didn't finish reading jesus's
words afterwards which if you do it
explains it away and you understand
what's going on but if rich people can't
get to heaven
that means that the work that jesus did
on the cross and shed his blood
is not strong enough to cover rich
people there's an exemption there that's
called heresy uh
in doctrinal studies yeah okay that is a
type of heresy and it's called
gnosticism gosh and so you know this i
you little socialists who go rich people
can't get into heaven you're actually
heretics
i don't the idea that you dismiss
somebody out of hand their character who
they are how
based on their net worth
seems like the the
a loaf
it seems like the lowest form of
critical insight kind of feels like
there's an agenda it's just
so reductive and dismissive so i might
join rachel cruz in a conspiracy theory